keeper you know what i can't believe i'm
talking to you right now i thought you
would be in the top three for sure
um this really sucks it really does
i mean did you know after beth left that
you
knew you were threatened that you were
about to go home
yeah of course i knew i thought any of
them would have been nuts to keep me
um i've been playing a great game thus
far and
i was just really banking on pulling on
their heart strings to keep me
and like i said i was all out of tricks
and they got me they got you and that
eviction was probably one of the most
emotional moments of this season
uh i mean what does it mean to you that
you know the way we
erisa reacted to everybody the fact that
you were going home
that was a bit of a shock i could see in
my speech that orisa was kind of tearing
up and i was like
yo erisa chill like i need to get
through what i have to say because
i had that speech planned from the very
beginning that was always going to be
how i left with my traditional name
with uh you know saying who my father
was and who my mother was
um but yeah i you just never know what
kind of
impact you have on the outside world
because you're just so involved with
what's going on in the house
yeah and you truly did have an impact
you talked about your heritage
you represented haida and i mean for
canada for you to use your voice
for everybody in canada to be to be
heard that must be special to you
yeah i'm not quite sure the impact that
it had
yet uh because i'm here chilling the
jury but
uh it was special and i felt i feel very
privileged that i had the ability to do
so
because as an indigenous person we don't
often have these type of platforms to
talk about the things that i was
bringing forward
so yeah i feel i feel blessed what does
it mean for you to be part of such a
diverse group of
house guests it was pretty spectacular
yeah i mean going in there it was just
it it just felt kind of normal to me
it felt like this is how it should be
this is canada it was a great
representation it was crazy to see all
of our differences
but then all of our similarities through
issues from social issues through diet
through
social interaction it was very
eye-opening and it made me feel very
comforting
to to be from such a beautiful place now
keeper in the beginning i thought you
were going to go home like
you know everything was playing against
you and then you came out strong winning
all the challenges here and there and
i mean what are you most proud of about
your game
uh um i got to go back to that first
veto win
it was very surreal it was the first
veto competition of the year
i was on the block i got to pull myself
off the block
i got to wear the the veto necklace um
because when you're in hoh you know you
get the room but you don't have that
the thing that signifies you one so yeah
the first video win was
was pretty huge pretty huge okay now
there's three left
there's ty there's braden there's tara
uh are you happy with the last three
yeah i'm extremely happy with the last
three i mean those are three of my
closest allies for the past couple weeks
um i think the only one who probably
wouldn't have caught me would have been
potentially braden
so it just played out how it played out
and i'm honored to say any of their
names on finale night it's really going
to come down to the final competition
and how they answer the questions from
the jury under pressure is going to
decide who wins
it's all up in the air now you're new to
the jury house so i can ask you this
question who do you think will win
who do i think will win i think sean is
going to win
okay and who do you think deserves to
win i think
uh they all deserve to win that's a
that's a really tough question
being in that house is different i think
only house guests and former house
guests can realize how tough it truly is
so everyone who's left in the house is
deserving of the
of the title and the money keeper what
if what did you learn about yourself
through this process i mean
you know this is self you know we went
from the current climate to you getting
isolated into this house
with these house guests i mean it must
been a moment for you
yeah in that house you get to reflect a
lot on the decisions you've made in life
just like the house
i've learned that i'm a bit more
resilient than i thought tend to
i tend to be able to give up on things
easier and in there
myself but never to give up i had a once
in a lifetime opportunity
and i really rose to the occasion on a
number of occasions
when i needed to and i also didn't know
that my leadership skills would
translate into the house but i feel like
they did
my ability to motivate people and get
people to
i don't want to say do up what i want
but get them on the same page as me
that surprised me a lot yeah and what
does it mean that you were
on the show for your family oh
yo my family is huge big brother fans
they're gonna be wilding out i know this
uh my sister's gonna have a million
questions for me i think they're going
to be very proud
of the game that i played and
represented i didn't go out first you
know that's
everybody worried i made it to the final
four i was at the bb count awards and i
got taken out
because i was the best player in the
house hands down
congratulations it was wonderful
watching you and i just want to say
thank you for using your voice and your
platform on this show so
you'll be extra surprised when you watch
the season back of
the impact d-pad so thank you thank you
thank you it was an
honor and the london i love you all